أعتقد أن المحكمة تعرضت ل
ضغط قوي جدا
وأن هذه الضغوط التي جلبتها
على نحو فعال
إلى الصياغة النهائية
لكن أعتقد أنه جاك شيراك لديه
فعل الكثير حتى تتمكن المحكمة من ذلك
التدخل كان هناك في جميع أنحاء
إجراء الكثير من الضغط و
في الواقع أنه في نهاية هذا مزدوج
النسبة التي ليست هي نفسها بالضبط
ابتسامة
بينما لم يتم التوصل إليه أخيرًا
أو كما يمكن أن نتخيلها
بسهولة تامة في البداية
تقرير ذكرته
لأن القتل جريمة
مثل الرئيس الحريري
واحد أخيرًا من رئيس الوزراء هاري
زبون والبعض مطلوب
معذرة
معهم
كانت هناك ضغوط بلا شك
أن الأسماء لا تظهر
أعتقد أن هذا هو السبب وهذا جيد
أيضا السبب
العلاقات مع سوريا كذلك
معقد
أعتقد أن النظام الغذائي الأول أولاً
فكر في النظام الغذائي نفسه
نعم
لذلك لن أخبرك كيف
لحظة حدوث ذلك ولكنه واضح
عندما نرى الإجراء
صعوبات إجرائية
حتى الحكم الذي كان هناك
ضغوط أنني لم أكن هناك وأنا
لم يكن عضوا في المحكمة بالنسبة له
أقول ولكن كان هناك ضغط على
تخفيف الماء بطريقة أو بأخرى
التقرير الأخير